das ist schon eine wenig verrückte idee
aber am ende vielleicht nicht so blöd
china will einen künstlichen zweiter
mond ins all schicken
der himmelskörper sollen nachts licht
zur erde schicken damit eine stadt
erleuchtet werden kann der effekt es
kann eine menge energie gespart werden
weil die straßenbeleuchtung
ausgeschaltet werden kann
schöne idee aber wie will man einen
ganzen mond ins all schicken und was
passierte alles noch in china klicks um
science-fiction bei uns gibt es jeden
tag ein video mit spannenden facts news
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts okay let's go herzlich
willkommen eine absolut geniale idee und
sie wird schon länger überlegt aber in
china macht man seit einigen jahren
nägel mit köpfen ok erstmal zu beginn
einen ganzen mond schießen die chinesen
natürlich nicht ins all woher und womit
usw technisch nicht machbar
aber es geht kleiner aber genauso
effektiv zumindest für eine stadt 2020
soll ein satellit auf eine geostationäre
bahn geschickt werden so wird zumindest
vermutet der zumindest eine ganze stadt
beleuchten kann setzt das ist erst mal
eine herausforderung schenk du heißt die
stadt die als erstes ihre
straßenbeleuchtung ausschalten können
soll
wohlgemerkt können soll es ist ein
experiment niemand weiß ob es wirklich
so hundertprozentig funktioniert wie
geplant bei den russen sind solche
experimente in den 90er jahren schief
gegangen aber wenn es funktioniert
könnte es die energiewende weltweit
revolutionieren und wie es funktioniert
darüber hüllt sich china in schweigen
eins ist sicher der satellit soll
sonnenlicht auf die erde reflektieren
das geht nur auf einer geostationären
bahn denn nur von dort kann zuverlässig
ein punkt auf der erde anvisiert werden
nächte sind dort viel kürzer weil der
erdschatten so kleines maximaldauer die
nacht war die nach jahreszeit 70 minuten
und auf dem geostationären orbit gibt es
nur zwei stabile punkte an denen die
satelliten bahn nicht ständig korrigiert
werden müssten
für china wäre das 75 grad ost optimal
von dort aus wäre der satellit wegen der
großen höhe sogar in der lage sie städte
auszusuchen wie der satellit allerdings
genau konstruiertes dazu hüllt sich das
entwicklungsteam in schweigen
nur so viel ließ man durchsickern der
satellit soll acht mal so hell wie der
mond sein das würde zur
straßenbeleuchtung ausreichend das
gebiet das beleuchtet werden könnte
würde einen durchmesser von 10 bis 80
kilometern haben ein gigantisches
projekt es gibt aber auch kritik wie er
reagiert die tierwelt wenn so große
bereich beleuchtet werden und der plan
wird wieder mal ein schlaglicht auf die
ambitionierte wissenschaftsszene in
china inzwischen pumpt die regierung
dort milliarden in die raumfahrt dieses
jahr könnten dort zum ersten mal mehr
raketen starten als in den usa
2020 beginnen die chinesen mit dem bau
einer raumstation iss dann verschrottet
werden muss dann gehört die einzige
raumstation im orbit china schon etwas
bedenklich dass eine diktatur die regie
im weltraum übernimmt und auch bei den
mond satelliten will man dranbleiben
klappt das experiment sollen 2022 schon
drei weitere künstliche monde in den
erdorbit staaten war
da wird nicht groß gefackelt sondern
einfach mal gemacht wenn ihr dazu und zu
allen weiteren themen kein video
verpassen wollt dann endet meine nummer
bei whatsapp dafür hier draufklicken
dann bekommt ihr den link zum aktuellen
video täglich persönlich noch vor allen
andern von mir und zur begrüßung gibt es
ein kleines geschenk ich freue mich auf
euch hier geht es weiter drunter dafür
auch draufklicken china plant mascolo
nie bis dann bleibt dran